hey everybody welcome to new series and
planet coaster this will be quite a
short one it's really only for the beta
of the game and in it I'll be working on
this RMC wooden coaster that will follow
this natural terrain and that's also
really where I want to put the focus of
this series I might definitely get into
some scenery aspects later on but for
now I want to focus mostly on creating
the most realistic and hopefully also
fun layouts of the RMC coaster and
getting the natural environment in with
a lot of focus on the textures and the
shaping of the rock work and detailed
foliage to see how realistic you can
really go in planet coaster another
reason for this weather a couple of
reasons first off I haven't really done
this so much in Planet curves too much
of my stuff so far really focused on
scenery in terms of buildings and in
terms of laying out parks not so much on
coaster realism or landscapes even
though both of these things are quite
large passions for me so I really wanted
to try that but also I just have to say
and I cannot overstate this I just love
the are emcees that have been added into
the game I've always wanted to get some
our emcees into the game and the way
that they've been made is so good the
realistic like elements of it are there
it's very detailed just making the
tracks is so satisfying and in the end
I'm just so happy with how the tracks
look that I I find it hard to do
anything else but just making our emcees
over and over again so that's what we're
doing here I really just wanted to mess
around with this and turn it into a
short series and see how much you can
really do with this game and how good
this game can really look so the layout
of the coaster as you might already be
able to tell is quite a standard sort of
RMC terrain conforming woody if there's
really even such a thing the beginning
especially is inspired by wildfire
though I would say the biggest
inspiration that I took from wildfire in
terms of this coaster is really in the
environment of it wildfire really
follows those kind of rocky cliffs that
it has in the surrounding area and
that's really what I want to do with
this coaster as well so while some of
the parts right now my
be floating like pretty high in midair
like about 20 or 30 meters it'll all be
quite close to the ground and many of
these steep drops will be following
their the very rocky cliff facades that
I want to have in here in the future but
also I took some inspiration from
storm-chaser especially in the the kind
of size that the coaster has since storm
chaser is the smallest of the RMC
coasters it's a little over 30 meters
tall and I think this coaster is just a
little bit taller than that so in order
to still make this coaster seem like
it's very fast I definitely wanted to
get the get the elements in as compactly
as possible and make sure that it's
still quite a thrilling and well intense
looking ride despite the fact that it's
relatively small so I'll be taking some
elements like inspiration from that as
well and some parts are a bit like
wicked cyclone as well which is just an
amazing coaster as well I guess I could
stop talking about our emcees in real
life because they're all really good but
the gist of it is basically that this
coaster is kind of an amalgamation with
all the different parts of our MCS and
some of my favorite our MCS really out
there in terms of what would be the best
elements to fit together and it's all
going to be neatly packed into this
terrain coaster with a hopefully nice
interaction with the natural
environments to create a pretty fun ride
in the end so the layout starts out with
a very wild fire like first part just a
small pre drop section where it has that
small overbank turn into the first drop
which is the standard sort of RMC steep
drop into an airtime Hill into a zero-g
roll where it goes with an over-banked
turn which is going to be all on top of
some rock facades it's gonna go back
down into the valley which most of this
coaster is going to be in and in the end
have a couple of like double downs and
twists and turns into the zero-g stall
which I'm working on right here and
really after this point the entire
coaster is just gonna remain very low
and close to the ground because
basically this coaster isn't that tall
but I wanted this coaster to really feel
like it's not
losing any speed throughout the entire
ride so while at the beginning it sort
of skims its way between these rocky
facades and goes up the mountains every
now and then at the ending so like
really the second half of the coaster I
wanted it to stay quite fast and just
have all of these airtime Hills and
small over-banked turns in the valley
which is really gonna sit in between the
large mountains of this area oh so
that's the yeah that's the point where
we're at right now just wanted to put a
quick double down in there because those
are always cool and a over-banked turn
into the first stone of the coaster
right after the first drop here and that
is really just about probably the most
important or interesting part of the
ride so far the rest of finishing the
coaster layout here is just a lot of
these smaller hills and a couple of
terms to make it back into the station I
just wanted to make sure that the ending
part of the coaster doesn't feel like
you're just slowly riding it out into
the station so this is going to stay
very close to the ground and have a lot
of hopefully still pretty intense
elements despite the fact that it's
already lost quite a bit of speed over
here and hopefully all seem in the end I
haven't really tested it at this point
hopefully in the end it will seem like
it doesn't really lose any speed
throughout the ride and what you can't
really see as clearly right now but you
will be able to see quite clearly in the
future is that this ending point will
sit right in between these hills that
all like sort of that the coaster is
going to sit between in the end so we
have this valley in the middle and in
the middle of that valley now it's going
to be a river which it has some
interaction with as well and especially
at the ending part of the coaster it's
going to come very close to that
riverbank it's actually quite a bit
lower than the station itself and only
really at the end of the coaster it's
gonna finally go up quite a bit straight
into the break run of the coaster and
that'll hopefully make sure that it has
the best ride with the least amount of
kinetic energy wasted which I'm quite
happy with and that's really it the
layout is almost finished at this point
I would say that the most important part
is finished I just wanted to make sure
that
I got the river in and got the young got
the hills in that really shaped this
Coast before I actually finish it so
that I actually have a good idea of what
this is going to look like in the end
and where the final parts of the track
can actually go to make sure that they
don't end up sitting in the way of
whatever scenery I really want to create
because the landscape over here for me
was actually quite important and it's
definitely a practice with the terrain
tools and with the terraforming tools in
the game as well now for awhile I
figured that I could just make a helix
over here and quickly go into the
station that way but that really didn't
work out I had barely any space left for
a break run let alone that it would even
be possible to add a transfer track so I
wanted to make the space into the
station quite a bit larger so the
coaster had to go on for just a little
bit more which is why in the end I
decided to move the river a little bit
allow the coaster to just kind of dip
down into the riverbank here get a bit
of airtime get some twists and turns at
the end and only with a final helix
which is moved a little bit further
really go into the break run of the
coaster which actually made before I
actually finished the coaster itself
just because I wanted to make sure that
the brake run actually goes down a
little bit and I understand why you
can't really do that in the game because
actually making a station that goes down
would be incredibly hard but I did want
to make the brake run that actually has
a very slight incline so I only had to
put some brakes in there and really just
minimal friction wheels so most of the
brake run does have that very slight
incline yet I wanted it to be perfectly
straight which is why I wanted to make
the brake run before I actually made the
rest of the coaster and at first I
figured I could actually have this this
quick turn before you go into the brake
run but that turned out to be quite
there are just that turned out yeah to
be quite a tight turn which I wasn't
really too happy with
and it's also a bit of slow point and I
really wanted to make sure that the
coaster just feels fast all the way
through and only really started losing
speed at the very last hill as you go up
to the break run so instead I wanted to
just quickly dip underneath the brake
run have that very small helix there
although that was admittedly a little
bit too small so I wanted to make it a
little bit larger have that slightly
larger helix right there at the end
before you actually go into the brake
run and that just about finishes the
layout of the coaster I'm actually
really happy with how the layout turns
out it's still quite fast in the end and
has a lot of the elements that I sort of
wanted to make sure it would have before
I went into making the coaster it's a
it's a fairly standard RMC layouts but
it doesn't feel like it's too much the
same like any existing RMC out there and
yeah overall I'm actually quite happy
with the coaster and it also interacts
quite nicely with the rest of the
environment which is the thing that I'll
be getting into from this points toward
the end of this video so as for the
environment like I said before I wanted
to have some rocky facades now the thing
the tricky thing here is that I never
really had much practice with this I
haven't been able to play the beta that
much so far but before I went into this
I quickly opened the terraforming menu
on an empty sandbox map to just kind of
play around with the textures that we
have and I am so happy with how the new
taxis are in this Alpine environment
they are so much better than the rocky
textures that we had before just in the
tropical section and is actually really
good for making um for making any kind
of rocky cliff facade as long as the
terraforming is quite rough and you have
those very vertical faces combined with
the more horizontal cross parts I think
it actually looks really good and one
other thing that I am really happy with
when it comes to the textures of the art
of the new biomes is actually that they
mix very well there are only eight
textures in the game which isn't that
much or they're only eight textures per
map which isn't that much and it was a
little bit afraid of this beforehand but
actually mix
very well you can very well just take
the soil texture and darken large
patches of grass with it the sand goes
very well with the rocky textures and
the two rocky textures mix very well
together as well to create a bit of
variety between the steeper and the less
steep rocky facades so I'll be really
using a lot of these textures and really
blending them together and mixing them
in different parts with a lot of trial
and error to be honest to create the
best looking rocks actually think it's
most visible on this side of the valley
since this is actually the side of the
valley where the Sun is at right now so
you can really see the way that these
rocks turn out and I am just so happy
with how these textures look they also
have that very slight bump mapping to
them so especially the in rougher rock
texture if you already have some
slightly rough vertical cliffs going on
can work really well with the grass
textures and putting just a little bit
of sand around that and in the end
covering the entire area with a very
very light brush of soil actually makes
everything a little bit darker and makes
everything pop out a little bit more and
I am really happy with how that turned
out so at this point I'm really just
making these cliffs
it's very inspired by the clips of
wildfire which also have these sort of
vertical cliffs in between the more
horizontal gentle parts of grassy
grassland and yeah that is pretty much
what I did at this point I didn't want
to make the entire hill rock and I also
didn't want to make the entire thing
cross so having this combination of the
vertical rocky cliffs mostly around the
coasters and around this side of the
river seemed like the most realistic and
the best-looking way to go about doing
this there are actually pretty large
sections of grass on top of these cliffs
assad's like the idea is really that the
rest of the hills that are quite smooth
and not as rocky and rugged but the
thing is there's a river in this valley
which kind of allows you to have that
idea that it's been eroded over time and
the rocky cliffs is kind of end
vertically at some point and that's
really perfectly where the coaster can
sit right in the middle of that valley
so that's really what I did with the
terraforming now I just wanted to cover
everything with a little bit of sand
here and there just to bring out the
rocks a little bit more and in the end
put a very light texture of soil
everywhere a little bit of sort of
shading almost with some darker rocks
here in there to make them come out a
little bit more and that is just about
it for the terraforming the final thing
that I wanted to do not really to finish
the coaster but to create an idea of how
this would look and how they coaster the
terraforming and the foliage work
together to create this one look which
hopefully should work together I wanted
to make the foliage in this small
section of the coaster just as a sort of
test as a kind of prototype of how I'm
gonna do the rest of the foliage and at
first I was sort of selecting trees and
seeing what trees go best with the rock
textures that I have over here actually
put a couple of tropical trees down
there anyway because they do look pretty
good but many of these trees I ended up
removing and going mostly with the
ponderosa pine which even though it's
American and the theme which I'm gonna
go for with this coaster isn't really
set so far but I was figuring that I
might turn this into a Russian theme but
even though that's an American pine
actually really like how that pine looks
and how it looks with the rocky textures
so the majority of the trees will really
be their ponderosa pine and I'm putting
all these different trees and bushes in
between just to have a bit of variety in
terms of the color and the textures of
the foliage and of course the shapes of
the trees as well but I guess well I
just mostly like about the ponderosa
pine is how it has a slightly washed out
more yellowish green texture than many
of the other trees in the game which are
often quite lush and very bright and I
really wanted to get that washed out
sort of rough northern kind of look to
this coastal environment so that's why I
mostly figured these pints would be very
useful and the rest of the foliage is
simple in a sense that I'm not using
many things but quite complicated in a
sense that I did want to put a lot of it
down there so most of the shrubbery
which I'm using here is really just that
sort of desert cross I actually forgot
the name of it but it's the yellow
flowery sort of grass which I figured
looks pretty much like dried sort of
overgrown grass and if you put them
together and played it in pretty dense
and large clusters they can actually end
up looking a lot like grass and just
putting a bunch of different more green
and more lush shrubs in there gives them
a bit of color as well and I feel is the
best way to kind of create this sort of
overgrown northern natural forest look
and what I'm also really happy with
which I haven't really talked about yet
is the new rocks the new rock textures
blend so well with the terraforming
textures and the foliage is well that I
just wanted to scatter some around the
areas especially underneath the the
cliff facades here
which just gives a little bit of an
extra touch into the environment anyway
that's just about it for this time apps
I don't really have any time left so
thank you guys for watching hope you
guys enjoyed this episode and stay tuned
for the next one I'll be finishing it
off with a couple of cinematic shots
you